مع انطلاقه العد العكسي لبدء موسم العرض
الرمضاني اليكم ابرز ما ستشاهدونه في
دراما رمضان 2023 من مصر سوريا لبنان
والخليج
[موسيقى]
وما فيش حاجه بتهون
وانا عملت ايه غلط في حياتي
تقدم معظم المسلسلات المصريه هذا الموسم
حكاياتها في 15 حلقه ويتناولوا معظمها
قضايا اجتماعيه منها ما يوصف بالشائك في
المجتمع المصري مع تركيز اللافت على قضايا
المراه كحقها في الوصايه على اولادها بعد
وفاه الزوج وحرمانها من الميراث في بعض
المجتمعات الريفيه وكفاحها لاعاله اسرتها
حتى لو اضطرت الاقتحام مهن او تولي
مسؤوليات اداريه قد تبدو حكرا على الرجال
وما يترتب على ذلك من تحديات مهنيه
واجتماعيه وربما عائليه حينما يتعلق الامر
بمحاربه الصور النمطيه والتصدي لسلوكيات
خاطئه
وتقدم دراما المصريه هذا الموسم قصصا
لشخصيات تخوض صراعاتها من اجل تحقيق الذات
والفوز بالحب بعضهم تحولوا لابطال شعبيين
واخرون اصبحوا خارجين عن القانون ويبغى
الاكشن على احداث الكثير من القصص التي
يسيطر عليها الغموض وتشعلها الخيانه
والخذلان والرغبه بالانتقام
[موسيقى]
انا من ساعه ما ابويا ما مات وانا شايل لك
كل حاجه لوحدي
ولا تخلوا دراما المصريه هذا الموسم من
قصص الحب الرومانسيه التي تواجه التحديات
ومن الثنائيات المنتظره لهذا الموسم مهره
وجابر الكوماندا الثنائيه التي يقدمها
الفنانين ياسمين عبد العزيز واحمد العوضي
ويركز عدد من الاعمال على العلاقات
الزوجيه والملل الذي يتسلل اليوميات
الازواج بعد الحب الذي كان بسبب ثقل
الاعباء العائليه ومعظم تلك القصص تقدم في
اطار كوميدي وللكوميديا حصه وافره على
قائمه العروض الرمضانيه لهذا الموسم ومن
ابرز الاعمال المنتظره الموسم السابع من
الكبير قوي بينما ينظر لعوده نجم
الكوميديه المصريه محمد سعد في مسلسل
الحاج اكسلانس بنوع من الترقب خاصه انه
يؤخذ عليه اعاده تقديم شخصيات سبق وان
قدمها للسينما
وتعود الاعمال التاريخيه الى قائمه العروض
الرمضانيه من الدراما المصريه هذا الموسم
وذلك من خلال مسلسل رساله الامام الذي
يتناول سيره محمد بن ادريس الشافعي كما
يقدم مسلسل سر الباتع نوعا من المقاربه
التاريخيه مع احداث العصر الراهن في دراما
تدور احداثها المتخيله بين
1798 والزمن الحالي الذي تنطلق منه عمليه
البحث عن اسطوره او لغز السلطان حامد وتضم
قائمه ما يوصف في المسلسلات الوطنيه عملا
واحدا فقط بعنوان الكتيبه 101
[موسيقى]
انا عاصم الزند مطلوب وجاي تسلم حالي اما
دراما السوريه فمنها ما يتناول قصص ابطال
شعبيين كما في مسلسلي الزند بالعاصي
والعربجي الذي يلخص صناعه حكايته بقصه نار
ولدت من رحم الظلم
اذا ما بخليك تمشي تحاكي حالك يا عبدو
العربجي وكالعاده هناك حصه وافره من
الانتاجات السوريه لحكايات تدور احداثها
في حالات الشام كقصه اختطاف ابناء زعماء
ثلاث حالات دمشقيه التي يرويها مسلسل مربى
العز بينما ياخذ مسلسل زقاق الجن اسمه من
احد احياء دمشق المعروفه وتدور احداثه
الافتراضيه حول سلسله من جرائم القتل يظن
الاهالي ان الجن مسؤولون عنها وعلى قائمه
العروض الرمضانيه السوريه لهذا العام موسم
ثالث من حاره القبه وثالث عشر من باب
الحاره سيشهد اخيرا خروج الفرنسيين من
البلاد
ومن المسلسلات السوريه المنتظره ايضا موسم
ثاني من مقابله مع السيد ادم الذي حقق
نجاحا جماهيريا كبيرا في موسمه الاول
ومسلسلي دوار شمالي وابتسم ايها الجنرال
وكلاهما يغوص في اروقه الصراع على النفوذ
والسلطه والفساد اما الكوميديا فتبدو
حصتها من قائمه الانتاجات السوريه ضئيله
جدا هذا الموسم وتقتصر على مسلسل قرار
وزير وموسم جديد من مسلسل صبايا الشهير
ياتي بعد غياب عشر سنوات ويشهد تجددا
اللقاء بين نور وميديا بعد التغييرات
كبيره طرات على حياتهما
[موسيقى]
ويحضر على قائمه المسلسلات اللبنانيه
السوريه المشتركه موسم ثالث من مسلسل
للموت وتتكرر ثنائيه مدينه نسيب نجيم وقصي
خولي في مسلسل واخيرا الذي يروي قصه حب
رومانسيه تواجه التحديات ويغوص مسلسل
النار بالنار في العلاقه الاشكاليه بين
السوريين واللبنانيين بحلوها ومورها
انا الحمل الكبير علي وهذا ريان خاف الله
واخيرا تركز دراما الخليجيه في موسم رمضان
2023 على القضايا الاسريه وتحديات التواصل
بين الاجيال والعلاقه المعقده بين الطبقات
الاجتماعيه وتتناول الفنانه الكويتيه سعاد
عبد الله قضايا تهم النساء في المجتمع
الخليجي من خلال المسلسل المجاريح وتعود
الفنانه حياه الفهد الى الكوميديا بمسلسل
جره عينك في الموسم الذي يشهد العوده
المنتظره لثنائي الكوميديه السعودي ناصر
القصبي وعبد الله السدحان في طاش 19